[Musique]
pour brut je me suis rendue en Arménie
une petite république du Caucase grande
comme la Bretagne et qui est coincé
entre la Turquie l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Iran
en fait j'ai voulu comprendre pourquoi
là-bas des femmes de mon âge comme
l'année se préparent à la guerre en 2020
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan se disputent
le haut Karaba c'est un territoire
majoritairement peuplé d'Arméniens mais
qui est situé en Azerbaïdjan le conflit
fait plus de 6000 morts et ce solde par
une défaite côté arménien et en fait on
en a très peu parlé mais il y a quelques
semaines ce conflit gelé a repris
puisque l'Azerbaïdjan a bombardé plus
d'une trentaine de communes sur le sol
arménien et ça ça a provoqué une onde de
choc parce que ça n'était jamais arrivé
auparavant et ça a poussé certaines
femmes comme l'année à prendre les armes
alors je me trouve à sotte que c'est un
petit village arménien à la frontière
avec l'Azerbaïdjan et qui a été bombardé
les 13 et 14 septembre dernier la
plupart des habitants ont fui j'en ai
peu croisé et ils font aujourd'hui
partie des 7600 déplacés depuis le début
de l'offensive militaire azerbaïdjanaise
ici dans cette maison il y avait 5
personnes qui vivaient ils ont réussi à
partir juste avant que la maison soit
bombardée ici on voit un linge qui était
en train de sécher dehors qui est
complètement carbonisé
[Applaudissements]
ça te donne beaucoup d'énergie et en
même temps tu penses toujours que je ne
veux pas utiliser ça jamais c'est ça
[Musique]
je dois me préparer pour le travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux tu montres
beaucoup les photos de ton entraînement
militaire est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression que ça glamourise aussi la
guerre modèle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en suivant l'année lors de ces
entraînements j'ai rencontré des
dizaines d'autres femmes
parfois des familles entières qui sont
elles aussi tournées vers la guerre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est une histoire de femme tu sais
ce sont les femmes qui qui élèvent leur
fils et qui accepte de les envoyer à la
guerre et ce sont elles qui souffrent le
plus je crois que dans toutes les
familles en Arménie tu trouveras pas une
mère qui n'a pas chanté en fait la
berceuse à son fils ça s'appelle zafnir
réveille-toi mon fils un gros seva et
défend ta patrie ta famille
[Applaudissements]
par exemple ce garçon c'est le garçon de
mon école ce garçon-là c'est le frère de
mon ami nous avons fait nos études
ensemble je sais qu'il a un garçon mais
ça ne touche beaucoup
et pourquoi tu viens ici des fois
parce que ici tu peux trouver des
garçons qui ont des vrais priorités pour
la vie et c'est grâce à ces garçons
qu'on a aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
c'est un peu différente parce que la
guerre n'est pas seulement dans la
frontières
c'est à l'intérieur tu dois rester forte
tu dois t'encourager des autres mais en
même temps tu écoutes toujours les
nouveaux tristes
le morte c'est parfois c'est difficile
d'encourager des autres mais tu n'as pas
le choix c'est ça
[Musique]
[Rires]